[Music]
today's news deals with some tough
subjects so you might not want your
children in the room we begin with Glee
star Mark Salling found dead of an
apparent suicide
the troubled actor was just weeks away
from being sentenced for possession of
child pornography
here the latest details just before noon
today the coroner removed the body of
actor Mark Salling from a remote area
north of Los Angeles the actor's car was
parked nearby he apparently committed
suicide selling was set to be sentenced
in March after pleading guilty to
possession of child pornography his
agreement stated that a search warrant
found more than 50,000 images of child
pornography on his computer and a thumb
drive the 35 year old was expected to
receive a prison sentence from between
four to seven years a source close to
the actor tells us last year he checked
into rehab after a suicide attempt
sallie ended a relationship with co-star
Naya Rivera in 2010 she told us in 2016
she wasn't shocked by his arrest he
always was a very dark soul to me and I
always felt like you know just from
knowing him so well I guess for the on
and off three years I just always felt
like there was something that he was
wrestling with selling had remained in
seclusion since being charged for
selling shot to fame as bad-boy Noah
Puckerman on Glee
puck is a jock obviously it's fun to
play a jerk you know and you don't have
to make him likable and
sooo and you booked this show and you
start doing and you put together you
have any idea what it would turn into
absolutely this was Sally's last big
public appearance at the Viper Room
relaunch at 2015 his attorney released a
statement this morning saying quote mark
was a gentle and loving person a person
of great creativity who was doing his
best to atone for some serious mistakes
and errors of judgment
[Music]